previously on model lifestyle be an
international male model you need to be
able to travel a lot you need to go to a
new country for two to three months and
stay there until your contract is
finished right now I'm on my way to my
new contract China so this is my model
agency here in Guangzhou China and then
here is my card over here what up so on
the left is the models and on the right
side you have the clients finally this
is us now you see there's a lot of
models in south
[Music]
sequences required
[Music]
[Music]
I have finally started to book some jobs
from the castings we had
and now I'm on the way to my first photo
shoot in China
he's young
I just arrived here in a the train
station
and this cue is so long
it doesn't stop it still doesn't stop
the queue still going
a lot of people in China sometimes they
don't wait in queue they just push in
like these people here
yeah
[Music]
how cute was that
the South Asia
are you in here
there's a nice guy trying to help me
showing me the way where to go it is
almost midnight
and I'm going to meet the driver take me
to the hotel for the job for tomorrow I
have just arrived in Shonto
[Music]
I'm still waiting for the client
driver is still late
I'm still waiting for the driver one of
the worst things for me of being a model
is to always wait for clients
yes oh okay
finally here I
all right
I only had four hours of sleep but it is
time to start the job Ianto is a small
city but there are still a lot of people
in the city this is my client today this
is my Chinese breakfast the modeling
market in China loves a lot of makeup
even for guys they would always put on
too much makeup but I should not
complain too much right because this is
a job
today we are shooting a lot for pyjamas
[Music]
our job as models this Amega clothes
look good let me just explain to you the
process the clients make the clothes we
models advertise it then the buyers from
all over the world come to China's
clothing market to select and buy their
clothes then it is packed transport it
to the airport and from there to
wherever you live
[Music]
so we got about 200 cloves today and
this is what we have to do the whole day
[Music]
this is real Chinese food
so this is the traditional kind of way
that they do tea here
it's really really nice if you take one
and take it like this right if you say
thank you
how do you say thank you you're the
Chinese it's put here you have to put it
down so let's break down if we dance and
somebody pour the tea in your car and
you need to insane
thank you lady not to say that
okay so you got it get the tea you have
to put it with your finger and you don't
need to say right it just means thank
you it means thank you bye
[Music]
[Music]
we just finished the job and now we're
late for the train so they have to rush
[Music]
we cannot find our driver this is the
craziness in China since class
[Music]
we just arrived it's ten minutes before
the train leave and we just arrived
Hey
my goodness
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so we just made it they are ready
to take off
[Music]
I just arrived in Guangzhou
and there are just so many people
there is 1.4 billion people in China so
I have to get used to people around me
all the time which is hard because I
really love my privacy
[Music]
we should
finally I'm home
[Music]
the Sun brought on the next day and with
it another job but then something really
bad happens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
many other gay a gay need of a passport
[Music]